The Saturdays of you losing someone like
that I don't think even to this day
sometimes when I wake up you don't
believe it and someone like that I've
never experienced like that it's so
early such a young age so it's gonna
take a while
mazie motion was it's tough you know the
entire memorial before a game was tough
tough for me to just to see and they
just say hear his voice and just you
know had to come to a realization that
you know that he's gone LA Lakers
players reacting to the death of
basketball icon Kobe Bryant following
Friday's game against the Portland Trail
Blazers it was the first game since Kobe
and eight others including his 13 year
old daughter Gianna were killed in a
tragic helicopter crash last Sunday do
you think very difficult I just think
that a lot of emotion when it comes to
out there obviously the crowd and trying
to I think it mourn slash trying to
celebrate just trying to grieve at the
same time and it's one thing about some
more sports can help with that but for
us to be able to play this game at this
time just just was tough we could see
out there you know it first quarter but
like a pickup game and guys won't really
do that you could see that communication
wise we were step slow and our energy it
took really to second half I thought
who's most energy getting offensive
rebounds and obviously Damian Lillard
found a good show stuff that we were
trying to do was it relief wasn't really
working up I'll kind of deflating for us
and then you want to win this game for
him obviously you have bigger goals with
his game something you wanted to try to
aspire to win but it was it was just
very difficult there's a lot of emotions
out there tonight
you know from everyone we obviously make
a fan base like her breasts front office
that's no big year for all this 20 years
you know some of the players have known
them coaches played against them played
with them
coach against or whatever you know
there's just a lot of emotions out there
tonight you know this week icon you know
quite a lot laughed a lot I cried so
much so I'm just really thinking about
know what he's still for and you know
what he meant to the game and you know
tonight I just try to be fearless
playing start to play my heart out the
Staples Center was filled with emotion
on Friday as the entire Court and night
were dedicated to Kobe and the others
who lost their lives boys to men uh sure
Wiz Khalifa and Charlie puth all paid
tribute through song while Lakers star
LeBron James gave a heartfelt speech
before the game started I wanted to make
sure I acknowledged daughter all the
lives that was lost Sunday morning and I
didn't want to mess that up for me
personally no just had that into words
just flow away from the heart you know
and whatever comes out not at their pure
Millis all truth to it so it just just
happened to spur the moment tears come
tears coming whatever emotion is it said
and obviously you want to praise his
career but someone you know I think this
you know I think he left before he came
forth to do everything supposed to on
this earth and I think his daughter I
have two daughters and having her on the
plane and what he meant to her life at
her you know basketball spying career
and so for us it's it's something that I
wanted to be experience it and my family
members one experiences and you hug your
kids you kiss your wife your girlfriend
a little bit tighter and hold it and you
know cuz obviously tomorrow's not
promised and I'm just glad we had here
to be able to start the morning and I'm
the more in the process here playing
this game from the this these great fans
life was just all beautiful he was
beautiful obviously it's tough losing
somebody
and no obviously there's a place a time
place to mourn but you know I think for
the most part that density more so about
celebrating someone's life all their
accomplishments you know
not just basketball conference but just
know life whether that's you know
obviously win it multiple say every sip
something you know the greatest things
in the world on the basketball court but
just being a good father
you know just being a good person you
know that's what we should all celebrate
and the teammates made it clear that
Kobe and his legacy will never be
forgotten
well Kobe and I meant for me personally
was obviously how extreme competitor who
had a championship caliber mindset
people say the mama mentality was to me
was a mentality of I do don't lose
mentality little Colvin and Browns the
first two guys they take me under that
wing going to show me the ropes and
showed me you know how to work how to be
professional and something I've always
cherished and no no I was able to learn
a lot you know from him and kind of just
go through my career and you know trying
to you know go to them them lessons he
taught me I won't lie you guys was there
definite difficult game difficult week
it's something that I don't know if it
gets easier and no time heals wounds
well this is someone who you know for us
is you know he was bigger than
basketball he's a global you see what he
how he impacted the game so we now have
said you know it doesn't get easier play
tomorrow and no matter what team so we
have to figure out a way you know how we
can harness this energy in the positive
and make this season a good one